[Music]
I'm not so concerned
with this this hand like
do you do you understand?
Um,
so as as she's going, I kind of just let
it be. Okay.
And the reason I tell you that Sean is
when you come around here, this is I
don't have that shape.
Do you see? I don't there. That's not
one of my shapes. I have this shape.
Okay.
So, when you do that shape that you're
doing,
this hand What? What's it What's it
doing to you?
>> What do you feel your hand do in
relation to the mat? Plotted in space.
>> Comes up.
>> It comes up.
>> Okay. So, what's the elbow hand trying
to do? Push down.
>> You get this. That's why you're losing
it. Okay. So, this hand
does the spiral. Do you see? And it fell
into place if it's there at all. Okay.
So, watch how I'm doing that.
I don't want to force this.
That's where I catch it. Okay. And
that's very wooue. I did my thing. Her
hand ended in my hand. chasing after it
is not wooue. So you're if wooi is my
path to the reconciling of yin and yang
non wooue is going to jack up my
yin-yang reconciliation and that hence
it's lifting it while I'm trying to push
down. Okay. So try it again.
Don't worry about the hand.
[Applause]
And then we got to find the the form.
Okay,
>> the form the form is necessary to teach
nonform
these two aspects
of that triune cosmogamy,
right? the the the uh
the unknowable,
right? Immaterial and knowable material.
Okay, you have to learn uh and navigate.
You have to learn how to navigate
through this dichotomy. So form will
teach you nonform, nonform will teach
you form.
Okay? And so you have to do the form.
You can't do whatever. So when I say
don't try for the hand,
you still must end up with the hand. Do
you understand? Okay. So go.
>> Those of you who keep looking for the
hand, come over here, Sean, because I
want the camera to see. Okay. And we'll
just we're just here.
Okay. Uh do you see where my my hand is?
Okay. His arm is eventually,
we'll do it here. His arm is eventually
going to end up
here.
Do you see that?
I don't need to go get it. Okay.
So, take out all the stance and stuff
and you'll see there's that. Do you see
Sean? Okay. Oh, as he's going down.
Okay. It gets right there. Do you see? I
don't grab for it.
The elbow keeps moving.
And there it is right there. Okay. Got
it.
>> Um, so this if you had La Gong, you'd
have this space. Okay. And as you're
coming around, I know at the beginning
it doesn't look like it's there. That's
why you're forcing it. Just leave it
there. Finish the adhesion. Finish the
inward spiral. His arm, his wrist ends
up right there. Okay? You don't you
don't need to do that stuff. That stuff
is not Marshall. You can't do that in
real life. It's energetically incorrect.
Um,
and whenever you see it working, you
have a uk who's leaving his hand up
there for you to do it. Do do you get
that? The reason it's not working on you
guys is because you're not trained to
leave your hand there. If you're pushing
my hand down, my hand goes down. So,
that's what's happening there. Okay. But
whenever you see, you know, Grandmaster
Shihan do it, you have some UK who
leaves his hand up there for him to do
that goofy thing. But no one fights like
that. Okay? And it doesn't it's a
violation of trapping rules. So trapping
rules are you end up in my trap. I
cannot chase you with my trap. You end
up in the trap. So imagine like a bear
trap and you leave the trap there and
the bear steps in the trap. You don't
walk around with the trap trying to
catch the bears. Okay? That's not how we
trap in any martial art except the la
land of modern iikido. Okay.